last time i talked to you you were still
dating
julia rose she claimed that you cheated
on her
any regrets with what has happened there
are you dating right now are you focused
on
unboxing and yourself um
you know well we'll see i
i don't um i don't i don't we might be
like
talking again or something but a lot of
rumors are just like made up
we'll yeah did he cheat her did he not
cheat no
no no i cheated on my math test
i listened to your podcast girl you made
some claims
we did make some claims she was talking
about that other
guy oh yeah the other jay paul you know
how did he win you back
um a facetime fall
that was all it took look at his face
okay can you blame me
are are you guys back together
officially yeah i guess so
i guess here we are here we are breaking
news
is this an et exclusive i think so last
time we talked he said he wanted to be a
young dad
you were serious about settling down do
you still feel that way i think we might
get married
oh you made it it's actually perfect
timing she's proposing to me right now
will you marry me yes could you guys get
married if you win
on august 29th
[Laughter]
i'm like yo i'm like why is katie asking
the questions for julia
i would like to see you guys
who knows who knows he's a knockout
tyrone first
yeah that's true all right so not single
i'm glad we set the record straight
there do you really see yourself calming
down like do you feel like boxing has
sort of helped you
figure out what you want in life is this
the number one
priority yeah no for sure it's like
helping find my purpose
and you know be focused on becoming the
best
version of myself been surrounding
myself with
with the best people in my life uh you
know boxing has allowed me to do that
and that's why i love this sport so much
i love that anything you want to say
before the match anything you want to
put out there tune in
you know it's going to be electric
performance and uh
don't blink you know what you buy the
pay-per-view be there august 29th if
you're in cleveland
come out uh rocket mortgage arena
tickets go on sale july 22nd
so i'm gonna get the job done and make
an entertaining night